bang Jeremy's in the house what's up man
it's good to be here in New York and
trying to survive the weather all right
Jeremy he's a legend crypto castle in
San Francisco we'll get into your
background in a second but you recently
moved to Miami and he won't shut up
about how it's cold and the weather
sucks in New York so we're gonna do this
and then you can get back down to Miami
I'm gonna hop on the flight all right
what the hell were you doing before
crypto I'm actually I'm in the midst of
writing a memoir right now are you
really yeah are you writing it or you
have like a ghost right I've got a guy
I'm writing it with I've got like 275
pages of unpublished writing lots of
blog posts when I got kicked out of
college and I was 18 I had like a an
anonymous blog that went pretty viral it
went and so I like to tuck her Mac style
yeah but I mean not not that sort of
debauch me more like adolescent ruckus
just I was a total miscreant growing up
and so there are a lot of great stories
pre crypto I don't even know how much
I'm gonna get into the crypto component
of my life in the book all right so what
were you doing right before you first
discover a Bitcoin yeah you say whatever
you want it's a free country made New
York Miami to say whatever you want I
you know I'll leave it at this you guys
can read the book uh-huh III was in some
fairly illegal activity based in New
York and Massachusetts where I was from
I just dropped out of my first college
and I was yeah I was neck deep in the
illicit activity yeah and some very
unfortunate series of events where some
bodies washed up in a river led me to go
back to college ended up at the
University of Michigan where I just
happen to you move in with a Bitcoin
enthusiast really yeah but but one thing
I should mention and I think it's very
interesting for you is that when I was
in college right boots
bikal and i had i developed my own major
it's very uncommon at the first school I
went to and even at ah Michigan where
the Honors College which I was a part of
allowed it it was very uncommon for
people to develop their a major I
developed this multidisciplinary study
and political strategy alright and this
was political studies microeconomics
mostly game theory social psychology and
military strategy in fact I was one of
the very first I was the very first non
cadet the CityU military strategy ed the
US Military Academy at West Point and so
it's amazing to think how I developed
the perfect major
for working in crypto I thought I was
going into politics but it turned out I
had developed just the perfect major for
what we do because it's all about
strategy and it's all about tactical
thinking it's always thinking about
several steps ahead and I know you have
a lot of experience with that and I'm
sure your time in the army has probably
informed the way you think about crypto
and crypto economics and how this whole
big macro game is being played for sure
when you move in with the Bitcoin
enthusiasts what a like what happens
he's like hey man you ever heard of
Internet magic money or well so his
name's canard Hawken hall and he's
what's the name canard Hawking Hall and
he he's an african-american young man
from the inner city of Detroit had his
house foreclosed upon his family during
the Great Recession became effectively
an anarchist as a result totally lost
his faith in banks and government and
and he actually started one of the very
first Bitcoin exchanges in the United
States so it was called bit box he was
in I want to say I think he's in the
first boost class Adam Draper's
accelerator and it ended up getting
defrauded via wire and he ended up
shutting down the company and he was
sleeping on the couch in my apartment
rebuilding his company back at Michigan
where he had he had been intending and
was also converting to Judaism because
had been part of this old Jewish
fraternity that we lived with and
decided he liked the religion great guy
fascinating but it's all he wanted to
talk about the other guys in the
apartment were really interested in
being my friend and I didn't know anyone
there and so I started to learn about
Bitcoin had learned about it like two
years prior in 2011 because of the Silk
Road I thought that was fascinating and
you know this black market amazon.com
but I actually found Bitcoin to be the
shitty part of that experience never
actually bought any but revisiting the
technology with canard
I really became endeared I had been at
Occupy Wall Street in 2010 and 2011 that
I had gone to school two hours up north
of here and every week and I had gone to
Zuccotti Park and protested the banks
and seen Zuccotti Park was lit back and
it was wild and it was it showed me and
someone that was serving political
strategy and very interested in the
whole concept of revolutions and how you
drastically disrupt a system
I thought maybe occupy could accomplish
something and they accomplished nothing
because all we did was protest with one
we didn't have demands but two how do
you just what do you get a bunch of
regulations that are burdensome for the
bank's know what it would take me two
years to realize and only upon
discovering Bitcoin was that you have to
create a new financial system and once I
realized what Bitcoin could be that I in
really this kind of frictionless way to
transact value we shouldn't send a
Bitcoin it's a concept of the blockchain
but nobody was talking about block to
you back then
we were just talking about a Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency blockchain was not really
term even back then you know there were
there was a space between block and
chain and we should we should discuss
how that was one of the greatest
marketing ploys ever developed by this
industry was shifting from Bitcoin
blockchain why why well I was just
saying I got so excited because I
realized it could be more than just
Internet money you know all value itself
could be transacted frictionlessly and
trustless leave between
buddy anywhere in the world with an
internet connection but the marketing
ploy so if you rewind I when did you
first get involved in the industry so
first I ever heard about it was in 2014
working at Facebook and I turned to an
engineer who literally was like this is
dumb and never thought about it didn't
google it and literally was the laziest
person on the planet and also probably
the dumbest cuz I should have obviously
at first yeah well in that and I'm right
technical and so I turned to the person
that I you know one of the people I
respected the most and asked them what
do you think well yeah he said it was
dumb okay you're lucky enough to have
engineers you know like until I was at
Michigan like up until I until I was
like 22 years old I didn't know any
computer scientists I didn't know any
developers I went to liberal arts school
I'm from a small farm town in
Massachusetts like there's nobody in my
life besides for buying drugs off the
internet that would be interested in
Bitcoin I didn't know libertarians I'm
from the most liberal city in America
like yeah I think there was no reason
for me to take Bitcoin seriously but
then I had this kid that had a very
poignant life experience and who I was
forced to hang out but that got me into
it but it probably wouldn't have
happened otherwise because bitcoin is it
is just very hard to understand concept
I mean I always thought gold was stupid
so I didn't even have that touchstone
but going to the marketing ploy I mean
in 2014 and this is why I asked 2014 mal
Cox imploded Charlie Shrem who just had
this on the show went to jail and most
publications pretty much either said or
intimated that bitcoin was dead and it
effectively was I mean nobody could get
banked banks that had been exploring
creating crypto currency exchanges
exploring the technology just you
weren't allowed to utter the world word
Bitcoin and a lot of big banks and the
world kind of forgot about the tech and
so what we did was there were a handful
of people who will go unnamed that
engage some of the top mark crisis PR
firms in the world so what did we do we
got the technology we're heavily
invested in it we think it's the future
but it's become toxic and yeah you can't
blame the media and most people from
thinking bitcoin was stupid in that it
was dead I mean it's only association
was with black markets frauds and tax I
mean there was nothing really redeeming
about Bitcoin at that point in time
except its potential and so what they
said was well how what is the innovation
in Bitcoin we started talking about this
idea of this distributed ledger the
blockchain if you will and we started
talking about blockchain technology
forget Bitcoin it's just this is this
new paradigm for transacting value that
the internet and the world has never had
before
and by doing that we created a world
word that could be uttered up banks that
could be uttered at fortune 500
companies by heads of state or our
members of parliament we created a new
phrasing that made this technology
acceptable even when Bitcoin was it and
so you know the bitcoiners were like how
dare they say blockchain is not Bitcoin
I was like [ __ ] yes that's that's
amazing that these guys are talking
about it when banks started talking
about blockchain technology in 2014 and
moreover in 2015 they single-handedly
saved this industry by legitimizing this
underlying innovation that was a part of
Bitcoin the blockchain they legitimize
Bitcoin unknowingly I truly think this
industry could have been squashed back
then if the banks had just not dabbled
in blockchain technology not talked
about it not done these proof-of-concept
trials not not said block chains not
Bitcoin but because they did Bitcoin was
able to really revitalize itself
industry it companies in the industry
were able to get funding and a lot of
those companies that were doing
blockchain not Bitcoin initiative
are now doing Bitcoin initiatives again
and so you know there are a lot of
heroes in the story of a Bitcoin but the
bank's play a really tremendous role
that a few individuals are willing to
recognize Visia legitimized blockchain
tech which is a big part of what bitcoin
is do you think any of the bank
executives hold Bitcoin oh for sure I
think it's a good I think it's like a
zero percent chance that they don't no
no no I mean III think it's beyond the
realm of doubt that many bank executives
do now some don't Jamie Dimon probably
doesn't miss daughter does you know
that's just as good in my mind you know
that speaks loads the technology but I
mean look I I I've got into crypto
because I wasn't an anarchist I wasn't a
libertarian but I thought Bitcoin and
blockchain technology could make the
world better and I believe it could help
disintermediate the banks who I had a
much bigger problem with than the
government so you'll love this because
it fits right into your story one of my
theories is that the reason why 25 to 35
year olds are so Pro crypto is that that
age group that 10 year gap is just old
enough when the global financial crisis
hits to be cognizant of what's going on
they see the housing market just
exploded they see people losing money
losing their wealth all this stuff but
they don't have enough wealth to
actually be affected themselves so they
see their parents being affected their
friends parents you know other people
that they know and it's the ability to
see it happen not be hurt by it and also
then realize all of those large
financial institutions that you're my
parents probably grew up thinking were
bulletproof those things aren't anything
near what you guys thought they were
right and so now 25 to 35 year olds are
hitting the stride of hey we've accessed
this new technology we actually don't
believe that those banks are fully
solvent right
you actually don't see that many like 15
to 20 year olds in my experience the 15
to 20 olds I'm not nearly as excited
about this as the 25 to 35 girls they
want fortnight and c-bucs and it's crazy
that's because you you got it right but
you missed you missed something that's
really important for Millennials so
Millennials cut off at 25 pretty much
you know they're old enough to remember
dial-up internet a world without mobile
phones yep but not really a world before
that for the most part and I mean I mean
the the later the older ones can
remember world without the web barely
but what we have all lived through this
unifying experience starts before the
Great Recession it starts with 9/11 9/11
I was in eighth grade
yes 9/11 is the essential moment for
Millennials because what it represented
was a shift in how we think about
privacy in the world in which Orwell's
1985 actually started to become a
reality and you know what in 2019 it is
1985 it's just later than he predicted
we live in this growingly Orwellian
world and then so since 2001 we've seen
our rights taken away we've seen our
privacy taken away we've seen the growth
of oligopolistic internet companies that
that kind of harvests all of our data
and we've we don't like it humans have
an inherent desire towards some form of
privacy not total privacy some form of
privacy and then we had then we had the
Great Recession and all of a sudden we
saw how the bank's just [ __ ] us they
don't care that they are money-making
capitalistic enterprises that really
just don't give a [ __ ] about the
individual and because of that you have
Millennials who now have grown up in a
world where privacy is an afterthought
where the government doesn't care about
the individual not have they ever have
but you can actually see that now
especially with like agencies like ice
which has become more
these days and then you see uh and then
you see that the financial system
implode and you and you see it get
rebuilt in a way that only benefits the
companies that causes its implosion and
so yeah well why not is not why not
believe in something that has only a
slight chance of success today's that
has it's much greater I'd say the
success of cryptocurrency and 50%
I have blockchain technology it's great
over 50 I think that Bitcoin bitcoins
potential as the global reserve currency
is over 50% I know that ok I'm not there
yet so what before we get into a whole
bunch of things that you believe some
that I think are very well documented
some that are controversial and then
some that I think majority agrees with
you on let's go through you leave
Michigan how do we get from Michigan to
crypto Castle in San Francisco what what
happens very short timeframe um but you
have to go back to Michigan so Kennard
shout out canard we need to get canard
on the canard on my guy I can make that
happen but what happened was that canard
had started two years prior I believe
the Michigan Bitcoin Club okay and he is
like we're restarting it he's like I've
got this guy from my former fraternity
Danny block he was this really hilarious
pothead from Ohio that was gonna lead
the Michigan Bitcoin Club and he's like
you should join and be a part of it it's
got nothing better to do so I was like
okay I'll go and at the very first
Michigan Bitcoin Club meet up a reporter
shows up from USA Today and she's if she
wants to talk to us about Bitcoin in our
club and I don't really have much to
offer because I'm fairly new but we
speak to her and part way through the
interview she mentions that their
Bitcoin clubs at MIT and Stanford and at
that moment I see an organizing
opportunity
I had worked for the governor of
Massachusetts that past summer and that
fall when I dropped out of school doing
some of that illicit stuff I was also
helping running the campaign of the
woman who's now Attorney General of
Massachusetts and the irony of that is
not lost on me you know I you know well
I worked at that it's funny I uh you
know people really just hate how I talk
about privilege and being white like on
Twitter and and the libertarians and
anarchists just bash me and I get
unfollowed every time I talk about it
but worked at the Massachusetts
Commission against discrimination and I
just saw how radically different people
that are not white straight males are
treated and I realized that I was gone
going to spend my life first illicitly
but then it's in a much more socially
beneficial way through what I'm doing
now um by taking advantage of the
privilege I have and recognizing it and
not shying away from the privilege that
I have so it was it was a really
instructive experience and it definitely
taught me how to avoid getting in
trouble at the police um once again
story for another day regardless I got
really dismayed by the bureaucracy in
government and and and the total
inefficiencies and I but I did learn how
to organize politically and so I saw
this organizing experience or
opportunity uh at Michigan with these
MIT and Sanford clubs and so I asked for
the journalists put me in touch with
them
I just thought something might happen
and so I'm gonna name drop right now cuz
it's so funny who was on on those calls
so the head of the MIT Bitcoin clubs
were Danny litzer who's now does
ventures at the ideal lab it was Ryan
sulcus who now runs Masari crypto here
in New York
I'm from Stanford it was Andy Bromberg
who's now the president of coinless and
Ryan Breslow who started bolt I mean it
was just a rock star cast of my first
real call in crypto and and I get and I
get on I call that same night because
the Stanford and MIT guys had already
had something planned and they're all
talking about the
respective successes and failures as as
clubs offering to share resources with
one another and advise our talking about
their potential hundred-dollar Bitcoin
drop and the first college conference
there seems to be a lot of opportunity
Ryan and Andy who have gone on to become
to my best friends we dropped out to
school at the same time together we're
very small getting to want to tell us
about anything they were doing but you
know III felt like we could do something
with these groups at the end of the call
I suggested hey why don't we create an
organization out of this and everyone
was like sure go ahead we don't have
time for that but we'll be a part of it
kind of but I used their names and I
created what was called the College
cryptocurrency Network I got on every
Bitcoin group every channel every social
media and I just spoke to me well I'm
like hey you're a college student you're
interested in Bitcoin come start a
chapter of this organization and I don't
know what happened I think I think it
was probably GOx imploding that brought
attention to Bitcoin to so many young
people but within three months we had
incorporated and had a hundred chapters
and 20 plus countries on every habitable
continent I mean it was just an
extraordinary success I was asked to
speak at conferences and then through
and then through what would become the
block teen education network as it is
know now I met Joey Krug who is this
brilliant eighteen year old computer
scientist he wanted to start a
point-of-sale system for crypto and we
decided decided to build it together I
mean he's just super smart I was like
you and i waz nyet jobs let's do that
let's do this Who am I Steve Jobs
destiny really you know Joey so
enigmatic he can do anything you know I
he was obviously the programmer but you
know he's brilliant you know he now runs
a hundred million dollar hedge fund you
know the youngest person in the world to
ever do that I mean crazy I mean he is
he I got so lucky meeting him and so he
was actually from a small town and
annoying so I plan to spend the summer
working on the nonprofit that summer so
as like hey just like come to Michigan
and spend a few weeks here and work on
the company I got him to some crypto
conferences in Chicago and we just spent
a bunch of time together and we
developed a real kind of Brotherhood and
then we decided we started to get
traction around the end of the summer
the the nonprofit was doing well as well
we had raised you know a couple hundred
thousand dollars from a few crypto
companies and so Joey and I decided to
take the leap of faith well not exactly
Joey decided to take a leave of absence
from Pomona where he was in school I
given my incredibly turbulent academic
career getting kicked out dropping out
you know going from a horrible student
to pretty much straight A's in college I
really didn't want to drop out of school
I had one year left I what's going into
my senior year and I was supposed to
take one class each semester and then
work on my senior thesis so I could
focus on my nonprofit him I start up and
then and so I was like Joey
I don't know I'm down to work on this
from school but like I don't know if I
really want to drop out and focus on
this full-time like my parents will hate
me and then what happened was I got a
call from the Dean of the Honors College
and she's like can you come in and I'm
like I don't think I did anything wrong
for once haha the office it turns out
that they had run an audit of my
transcript and I had too many
out-of-state credits so I had more than
enough credits to graduate if I had
gotten them in the state of Michigan but
because I hadn't gotten my credits in
the state of Michigan and all my AP
credits they didn't count I and I had
maxed out my credit limit from out of
state and all of a sudden in order for
me to graduate on time I would have had
to take like eight classes each semester
or been in college for like a whole
extra semester after the following year
in addition to taking being neck Deacon
deep in courses and the Dean of the
Honors College for the
Simon her career told me to drop out of
school she's like I've never done this
before but I see what you're doing with
your nonprofit I see what you're doing
with your startup and if you ever need
to come back here you can and that's all
I needed you know it was a very quick
conversation it felt like destiny I knew
that Bitcoin blockchain technology maybe
had it this is a summer 2014 maybe had a
10% chance of succeeding but I knew I
knew just down in my gut that if it did
succeed and I stayed in school and left
behind the nonprofit left behind the
startup I would regret it for the rest
of my life and that's what I told my
parents and I was like look if in two
years this hasn't worked out I'll find
my way find a way to pay my way back
into school and I'll go back to school
and I'll finish but I gotta go do this
Bitcoin thing and so I ended up dropping
out like two weeks wait years this
Nestor started summer of 2014
okay and so Joey and I dropped out of
school and then we were like wait we
don't have any money nothing like I had
some money in the stock market but like
I was like oh I don't really want I
don't want to sell that and then we got
contacted by a startup that was gonna be
based in LA that had raised some angel
money there like and I'd been talking to
them as they wanted to do marketing
through my nonprofit they're like why
don't you come join us as contractors
and Joanna and I were like well we need
money and it provides housing and so we
moved out to LA and it was just the most
disastrous scenario you could imagine
Joey just came out to me when I got to
the house and he was like I don't know
what we got ourselves into I mean it was
it was bad the the the CEO go unnamed
had just lost his mind was off his meds
I just had a child out of wedlock nobody
really knew what they were doing the
company had no direction and it was uh
it was the most stressful two months
three months of my life I mean the whole
longer experience was but that that
initial period where we dropped out of
school
bucho California's like I could be in
college I had a great girlfriend back at
Michigan like it was the first real
girlfriend I'd ever had I was like
everything was going well for me at
Michigan and now I've just dropped out
to do this Bitcoin [ __ ] that's probably
gonna fail what am I doing here but so
how do you get from LA to San Francisco
so Joey and I are you know we're
pitching this point-of-sale startup that
takes credit cards and Bitcoin payments
there was the the switch to the chip and
dep system from swipe that beginning in
2015 so join our like we'll create this
new startup that implements a chip
reader and also takes crypto payments we
created actually the farthest Bluetooth
low-energy
bit for Bitcoin payments and actually
even did sound base transactions for
Bitcoin which is very cool but then so
this company's trying to figure out what
it's doing is a total disaster but then
we stumble upon a white paper for a
decentralized prediction market platform
it was Paul Stuart's truth coin and I
was like now this is a great idea I made
a bunch of money I'm predict on in trade
back in 2012 in 2008 on the presidential
elections I was I just was really good
at like betting on delectable and
college outcomes
I made thousands of dollars in high
school in college and then Saul
intrigued it shut down there are no real
prediction market platform so I saw the
need potentially for decentralization
now obviously at that time it was the
first fad of decentralized all the
things in fact bitpay even had a sticker
that said that but I thought most
decentralized thinks decentralized
things people were talking about we're
pretty stupid decentralize read it
Twitter or Facebook whatever it just it
didn't make a lot of sense back then you
know there was really only Bitcoin and a
bunch of crappy old coins and so I
didn't really get that but decentralized
prediction markets made a lot of sense
now I'm like Joey I I think we have to
do this and
he agreed and and we start talking to
the team we're not sure about the guy
that's a CEO like we're like I don't
think we can keep this guy around but
but who we end up deciding you know we
can't do this in LA there's no resources
here it's the first place where or the
second time I met Brock Pierre suit and
become my colleague at blockchain
capital and you know he's like look I've
worked in the world of gambling for a
long time and you guys are probably
gonna go to jail for this
stay with the payment the payment system
but I I just felt this calling for
creating this decentralized global
source of truth and forecasting and so
I'm like guys like let's go move
somewhere where we can do this let's
move to San Francisco
let's go raise some money and maybe get
rid of that CEO and and we moved out to
San Francisco our house fell through two
days before we were on the drive up as
the guys were driving up to San
Francisco our housing fell through and I
was in I was speaking in Brussels at a
conference where I was hanging out with
Vitalik for one of the first times of
budding with him because we were the
only young guys speaking at the
conference and when I came back just our
housing situation was in nightmare
we found this dingy two-bedroom or
three-bedroom apartment out in Daly City
in San Francisco and I dubbed it the
Bitcoin basement because it's literally
the basement of the house which would
end up flooding like a month in I mean
it was it was roughing it in the most
quintal quintessential sense of the term
in terms of Silicon Valley startup so I
mean everything that went wrong could
you know employees quit you know we had
to get rid of the CEO and then and then
you know we started grinding and
eventually we raised a tiny bit of money
enough to get a house that would become
known as crypto Castle you know I just
like alliteration it was a house
overlooking the city and the Potrero
held neighborhood we couldn't afford an
office space we couldn't afford to live
separately we were taking $1,000
salaries but the crypto Castle seemed
like a nice name
especially because we wanted it to be a
hub for entrepreneurs and crypto people
to hang out because there was no place
like that back in 2014 or 2015 at this
point we moved in in January and so the
crypto castle was born as a result and
the hardship didn't stop but so when you
move in to crypto Castle what's the
general premise just you guys are gonna
live there you're gonna build it just
it's just a hafez for augur that was it
office yeah I never like a home office
that was it you know we couldn't afford
anything else and it worked but you know
there was also no place for the crypto
community to kind of get together and so
I used it to Google Maps I added a
Facebook page I talked about it
Vitalik would stay there when he was in
San Francisco and and I think that was
the key moment one of the times that
vitalik was staying a reporter from some
news website they never really took off
came to interview vitalik about etherium
and then we're so fascinated by our
house that she ended up breaking an
entire article about the crypto castle
and from then on it's just been a
touchstone for any journalists wanting
to coverage crypto and not wanting to
have to do the intellectual work
required to explain crypto there's no
just write about the crypto cast it's
much easier to talk about a house full
of Bitcoin enthusiasts and it is to talk
about crypto itself and so that led to
just an onslaught of press for the past
half decade pretty much yeah and so do
like a lineup of folks who paraded
through there over the first two years
pretty much everybody right yeah I mean
literally anyone that was in town in San
Francisco once it became well-known
would ask to stop by and the community
was so small back then yeah anybody
I came through I mean I my favorite
moment to this day was like three years
ago and vitalik was saying at the house
and Bram Cohen came over creator
BitTorrent now Chea network and
they had this very interesting
intellectual conversation and standoff
that was just one of the most amusing
engagements cuz they're all you know
they're both wonderful guys but both
kind of on the spectrum I think they
both say that and the interaction it was
just so just so beautifully nerdy you
know they're kind of challenging each
other on ideas but there's no and there
was never any this point of full-fledged
debate and I just that they're just
totally enamored with the conversation
it was it was just fascinating you know
we had there was there was another night
where we had I don't know the vitalik
was there but two of our other advisers
of augur Robin Hanson who's one of the
top academics when it comes to
prediction markets
Elizabeth Stark who would go on to found
the Lightning labs we were they were
there and we just had this long late
night of conversation you know and
everything I had at the castle either in
San Francisco or Miami I try to keep
spontaneous I don't I'm not like I'm
known as a partier but I don't like to
plan parties I just like to have things
happen you know have alcohol flow and
just you know have there be a
free-flowing dynamic where people can
converse without kind of apprehension
you know because all right so as you
guys in San Francisco you know how do
you end up working at watching capital
so we pulled off the first successful IC
o---- in almost a year
Oh with with augur and I was at my wit's
end at that point I I've been through so
much stress over the past year my life
doing augur that you know III wasn't
gonna last there were three probably
three years to three years left of
coding I wasn't a coder wanted to keep
costs low I had a falling-out with one
of my co-founders and left the project
and you know at that point I was because
this is kind of how these ICO dynamics
worked especially back then they were so
rudimentary
was fully vested ful so the economic
incentive wasn't really there and and
you know I didn't think the team needed
me as much back then in hindsight that
probably wasn't as true but you know
Brock who I got in didn't know on the
conference circuit was like come join my
firm in San Francisco where I was
already living as an entrepreneur as I
had kind of humored the idea with the
folks over at Pantera as well but you
know I went and sat down with Brad and
Bart Stevens the two brothers who run
blockchain capital now and kind of quiz
me told me augur was gonna get me sent
to jail yeah I mean everyone said that
back that you know theorem was probably
gonna fail they were so pretty Bitcoin
focused but obviously it started at a
firm called blockchain capital and you
know it seemed like a I had three no two
years ago two years prior after I
decided I didn't want to work in
politics I had been thinking of what are
my dream jobs like what do I want to do
after college I don't want to go into
politics anymore
and I had decided I wanted to become a
venture capitalist then I was reading
online is like the only way to become a
venture capitalist is to be investment
banker or adds experienced entrepreneur
turns out not to be true it's most
nepotistic industry but all of a sudden
flash forward two years after deciding
there's no way is ever gonna become a
venture capitalist because I did no one
no one had at that point of my life
identified my entrepreneurial instincts
as such and so I just like well I'm
screwed and if we're gonna become a VC
two years later the offers lands at my
door and I'm like sure I'll do it like I
was willing to do it for free you know
they'd offer me some carry on the fund
and that's like that's perfect you know
like I had enough money from the augur
ICO you know back pay from salary and
such that I felt comfortable and so I
was like yeah I'll do it
I'll go be a VC and it was a great time
because that was that was really the
depth of the first bear market and I
learned a lot learned a lot about
investing I mean the Stevens brothers
are
like as legacy VCS as it gets their
father started investment banking and
the west coast they're just total
rockstars they know exactly what they're
doing and then Brock and I are just like
soul brothers like we're just crazy wild
entrepreneurs and learning how to
balance those instincts between
professionalism and being outlandish
goobers was a really great thing at
probably what 24 25 years old so III
that was one of the best experiences I
could have had at that point what are
some of the companies that you guys
invested in while you were there so the
companies that we're I really helped
lead the investment the there were there
were a handful bolt which is my of Ryan
who I'd known for several years at that
point I started this payments company
that you know shifting between Bitcoin
and non Bitcoin but they they were
getting ready to launch and we invested
in them and they're really a exploded
and they just exploded I mean they're
just crushing it right missed that one I
talked to Ryan on the phone and a common
mistake so there's only two mistakes I
ever really make in investing and I
repeat them is if I lose sight of who
the founder is and I start falling in
love with the idea rather than the
founder yeah and then too is worrying
about the valuation yeah and the
valuation would cause hesitation but
they're rock stars Eric and Ryan the two
co-founders are just brilliant yep
classic Stanford did Silicon Valley
startup dropouts the love of the guys
and they're doing amazingly and they've
they've got some interesting stuff up
their sleeves and in regards to crypto
and then and then uh tyrion a wayne bond
startup i met him at the very first
consensus you know just allowing people
to easily hash onto the blockchain which
was at that time really one of the best
value propositions of the blockchain
bitcoin movement those kind of
timestamps you know i got very close
with micah winkles back from jam
really just that was a compelling
company just because mica just will is
just such a dynamic entrepreneur and you
know III learned so certain extent that
I probably not the best entrepreneur
like I am not a builder per se I am a
masterful delegator and so I can real
I'm really helpful with entrepreneurs
that need to build companies I'm really
helping them delegate focus on what they
need to focus on I'm much better at
helping entrepreneurs build companies
rather than building them myself
at that point I had built you know the
boss and Education Network and Hager but
I I was not I was becoming less certain
that I was a great CEO per se I knew
very quickly that I didn't want to scale
a company past a hundred employees and
that was a very important realization to
have because you know a lot of
entrepreneurs make that mistake they
think they're gonna see a company
through to an IPO and often they're not
the right person to do that but I said
but while there I started a distributed
magazine which is a hundred eight page
primer on blockchain technology comes
out twice a year through BTC media has a
website called distributed comm and it's
my favorite resource to give people that
I've never want to learn about Bostian
technology because it's print you sit
down with it you start from front to
finish and at the end you have a sense
of what blockchain technology is what
its potential is and so that was a
really great thing that I accomplished
while I be cap and then also helped them
structure the first tokenized security
ever so while i dogger i'd we created
the first utility token I then went to
create the first security token walk me
through the thought process as to why to
do that how did you guys structure it
what were the results it's so super
funny so with augur we didn't want to
create a token we didn't want to do an
ICO that was like terrifying we got rid
of the word ICO we called it a crowd
sale token sale we did the ICO is just
something like an IPO it sounded
horrible and for almost a year after we
created augur
Rep token and after our sale the term
ICO dissipated we we actually
effectively got rid of it and but then I
came back with a vengeance
haha well with augur what we did was we
realized that in order to have a
decentralized consensus or a
decentralized oracle if you will you you
had to have a token that was not ether
in order to create a turn history into
our story a collective recollection of
truth and it was scary but at that time
I didn't think that it would be that my
utility tokens I didn't see that many
use cases for utility tokens and frankly
I still don't you know there are
thousands in the world now but augur and
my views its rep token is still the best
utility token there is but what I didn't
predict was how many would come after it
now how many will remain is yet to be
seen but I think my original estimate by
the time that we created the first
utility token is that there will
probably be a few hundred in the world I
saw I heard Jeremy Alera on your podcast
earlier today saying that he thought
there would be thousands of utility
tokens now there may but I don't think
they'll have the high financial value I
think they'll have much more of a
governance utility more than anything
but but but but that experience should
have led me to realize that when we were
talking a blockchain capital a capital
about tokenizing our third fund that it
would lead to more than just tokenize
venture funds but we did it like I don't
know what the guys say but none of us
realized what Tok what tokenizing as
security could be know what nobody was
talking about we were realizing that a
lot of the ICO is coming out were
securities sort of like well we're gonna
call the 6-2 security because we know
it's a security but really the whole I
like I I thought the idea of tokenizing
assets was interesting but since no one
had done it no one was talking about it
it's hard to say that we I mean I know
as the fact that I didn't predict what
would come we thought you
we're democratizing venture capital
we're creating greater liquidity for LPS
but I really don't think that this
movement towards the tokenization of all
assets everything that is scarce in the
world that wasn't really on our mind I
and I don't want to take credit this
jest it was but sure enough just like
with utility tokens it's just been the
tsunami that's come since and you know I
I'd be very inclined to predict that
within a few years you know tokenized
securities tokenized real-world assets
will be the largest crypto asset class
in the world and it is just it's just
crazy to think that you know you can you
can pioneered these new forms of assets
and not even realize what you're doing
at the time you just you're just
thinking about what you're building and
then it just leads to this cascade of
innovation and scam so talking about
scams walk me through how you think some
of those early efforts with augur and
the blockchain capital token like where
do we divert from pretty reputable
legitimate projects that are you know
fairly transparent etc how do we divert
into what we saw 2017 like what like do
you think there was kind of
industry-wide mistakes that were made or
do you think that's just natural
when these markets go through the boom
and bust cycles you're gonna get the
scammers and the fraudsters that that is
the nature of the free market when you
have a new innovative open-source
technology cause anyone to raise and
make money they're gonna do it like
there was nothing we could have done to
prevent I mean I think I wish there were
more people like I you know people think
I'm like this ICO shell and think that I
have scammed a bunch of people for the
money I was frightened I thought
everything I was seeing was crap kids
keep in mind we had worked so hard on
not creating a token and realizing that
we
add two 4 auger why'd you have to be
because you can't have a decentralized
form of consensus on the blockchain if
it doesn't involve humans because you
can't have internet-based
input into a smart contract so in order
to say whether the Yankees won the World
Series or whether Trump was elected you
have to have a way to validate whether
that happen and that's what rap augers
tokin enabled was that thousands of
people around the world that owned that
token report on the outcome of events in
our incentive so is there a world where
let's say that you and I are on the
augur platform we make a bet that
Trump's gonna become president right you
say there's no way it's gonna happen
right no you say he is I say he's not
Iowa he becomes the president yet right
the risk factor or the attack vector to
Agra would be that the crowd reports he
did not become the president so when we
worked on this heavily this is this is
where my game theory came in it was
really helpful we randomized who
reported so you wouldn't want to report
on something that you thought wasn't
going to happen because you didn't know
whether you were going to be the one
reporting on that outcome
so because it's totally randomized who's
reporting on each outcome is it's next
to impossible to try to game that system
got it
very interesting and so then as you guys
did as you guys released auger right one
of the things that I'll play devil's
advocate for a minute please
one of the things that people will I
think push back on and say look it's
great that's decentralized it's super
interesting but it's really hard to use
right in terms of the user experience
user interface etc I mean it's better
it's gotten much better right but like
how do you think about the evolution of
the industry with augur and mind right
and I asked that as in like this is one
of the earliest versions of it was the
first app on the theory and we started
building on aetherium nine months before
it launched because we wrote a white
paper on how to build a decent choice
prediction market on top of Bitcoin and
turns out bitcoins not very good for
that and Vitalik who is you know the
only young speaker on the con
circuit who I knew well at that point
was just like and it healed prediction
markets he was actually already an
advisor to auger before this happened
but he suggested why don't you try
building on aetherium and we'll help
work with you guys to make sure the code
works in a way that allows you to build
this platform on top of it and you know
that was too early uh and it by all
measures we should have failed I mean
the idea that we were gonna build on a
blockchain that didn't exist yet that
everyone said was vaporware and was
never gonna work was the craziest thing
I've ever heard of I mean like no wonder
no one wanted to invest in us before our
AI CEO or give us a loan even because no
one thought oh I fear I'm what's gonna
work out I mean it was you know I mean I
guess it raised 18 million which was a
huge amount of money back then but you
know there is not a lot of people that
believed that etherion would be
successful let alone auger and and and
for all the right reasons I mean it was
super early I mean as a venture
capitalist today I mean in hindsight I
probably wouldn't have invested in that
I mean it was such a moonshot and
watching technology today you know fast
forward you know what four years and
it's still just in its Nason see this
technology is so new yet I get bitcoins
been around for 10 years for blockchain
technology like this the this layer of
innovation that can really be developed
upon primarily through aetherium but
also through Bitcoin and other block
chains you know we're talking about four
years I mean it is as new as a console
if you think about the web you had DARPA
net before it you had almost three
decades of development before it was
right for building infrastructure neat I
mean look if you had talked about
uploading videos to the web in 97 you
crazy and laughed at like you know that
and that was four years in that's five
years in like we're we're so early on
and you just have to acknowledge that
and so what's so essential
people hate centralization what is
essential is that you
create what I call third layer
applications so what's that so so what
you have is your the protocols which is
a theorem if the second layer which is
auger and then the third layer which is
a companies such as Vail which is a
Sequoia back startup that's creating
markets on top of augur but creates a
centralized interface for users so no
meta mask ideally no crypto you can use
credit cards but you can interface with
blockchain technology those are the
on-ramps you know anything without a
credit card anything without just a
browser-based interface or application
based interface it's not going to
succeed today it's really not I mean
there's some back end applications
absolutely but if you're trying to sell
products to consumers this technology is
not there yet it's not because the
theorem is bad it's not because any
Bitcoin is a slow transaction throughput
it's just the fact that the
infrastructure and the developments in
this technology are not there yet we're
very early we are creating a form of
value that in all of human history has
never existed it's it's web-based
totally decentralized value and that and
that is a paradigm that will take time
to develop it just doesn't happen
overnight and you know like like
infinitely scalable blockchain solutions
going to fix that there's a lot more to
building a sustainable crypto economy
and blockchain based economy than just
like like scalability or speed what do
you think about Bitcoin as a payment
today
rest you vent you originally got
incentivize or excited about Bitcoin in
crypto came in and now you have expanded
your view to a lot of utility tokens a
lot of block chains where do you stand
with Bitcoin so Bitcoin is a horrible
payment system I hold on before you go
to the negative side what do you what
are the good aspects of Bitcoin that you
snivelling is amazing I mean
is that it's in the broadest sense of
the term is a frictionless payment
system it is peer-to-peer it is just
like email you don't need a bank or you
don't need a government it is it's
dynamic micro payments or possible
censorship resistant it's totally global
it is the most exciting and it amongst
the top five most exciting innovations
of the 21st century what are the other
ones that you put up there I think I
think social media despite all of its
negatives is incredibly important I
think that the smart phone once again
just incredibly important I mean just so
games super alright what are the
negative sides of Bitcoin the negative
sides are a Bitcoin are very simple it
is it because it's deflationary it's a
volatile asset there because there's no
central bank it makes a horrible form of
money like yes I get like like white
privilege libertarians in America are
like oh it's sounding it's great but
guess what if you're 98 99 % of the
world or just look at America where the
vast majority of Americans cannot would
not know where to come up with $400 in
case of an emergency
volatility and your money is untenable
ah I I think the annualized volatility
of gold which is 7 trillion dollars in
market caps I don't know half trillion
in market cap um it's 15 percent that's
too much for an individual that doesn't
know where to come up with $400 think of
and then think about the rest of the
world
it's just crazy volatility does not work
for money people need reliable money
more than they need censorship resistant
money what do you vast majority of
circumstances what do you think about
the argument though that bitcoin was
more volatile in the beginning it's
gotten less volatile over time and all
we are is on like a 50 to 100 year cycle
where it will eventually be non-volatile
like
fiat currencies both it's just gonna
take time right there but it's what what
smarty cap today 200 billion of crypto
yeah probably coin Oh big no bitcoins
sixty billion
oh my god I don't look at the price
all right look sixty billion it needs
like even if it reaches the market cap
of gold which is 7 1/2 trillion that's
still too volatile is what I'm telling
you now I think my price point for
Bitcoin if it's successful it's about
three times that of gold I think it's 10
times better than gold but I think it
will be valued at three times gold
that's 21 trillion that's $1,000,000 a
Bitcoin it sounds crazy but I actually
believe that I think that's low I you
know it's hard to imagine I mean just
giving that we're at $4,000 a Bitcoin
you know it's crazy crazy crazy not like
people don't look at me but I give them
the math behind it it makes sense you
know it's better than Bitcoin gold in
every single way ten times better in my
view yeah giving it a three extra
premium on gold is not outrageous but
regardless that's it there there could
be a point where Bitcoin is non-volatile
but at that point I think in terms of a
pure Internet money we'll have found
something better now as a global reserve
currency could totally fill that niche
but and 15 percent annualized volatility
is not horrible uh but I'm not a great
either but it's not great and and you
have to expect it will be treated the
same as gold in terms of its volatility
and so it has a long way to go before
it's something that people can use every
day what about it atheria m-- what about
it what are your current thoughts if
cerium is the best bet for the
development of censorship resistant
applications I don't care what anyone
else yeah not money but application no
and neither was never supposed to be
money I mean the thing that is crazy now
it could become that I mean
they're very easy to quantify arguments
that etherium or ether could hate one
ethers called aetherium so let me use a
write nomenclature but ether could
become money but that's not its intended
use it no you're saying the etherium
network could be the foundation or the
protocol for calling decentralized
finance yep but but the non sensible
applications
yeah that's we think okay but is it but
what I love about Bitcoin and why I'm a
Bitcoin ball is because it is censorship
resistant money and that's it what I
what I hate and I I mean I'm just
traumatized by it is you know people
trying to tell me that bitcoin can do
everything okay it's great as this
censorship resistant form of digital
gold this digital store value but that's
what it's great at and there's no
indication that it's gonna be more than
that yay yes we have Lightning Network
yes we have all these other innovations
but fundamentally Bitcoin does one thing
really well and that's all I care about
because as I said if if people realize
it's ten times better than gold and it
has you know 3x premium on gold it's
worth a lot of money you know it's very
valuable and it's valuable to the world
and to certain extent it could become
this digital global reserve asset but
you know I think we're at the point
where innovation is a transcends just
Bitcoin in this space that we can expect
there to be a global digital currency
that is blockchain base that is true
truly decentralize it and it's not
Bitcoin and I think that's the likely
outcome what do you think about X or p
XR piece of best investment I ever made
probably will be ever will be I I
invested you know years ago I just as a
tiny head you is the when I after the
auger I see how I got back a bit of
money and I put all my money into crypto
it was primarily into Bitcoin into ether
then I put a little amount an extra peon
xrp just I mean talk about mooning I
mean fifteen thirty thousand per so but
it got up to like I bought at point zero
zero two cents or something and it went
up to like 350 375 and at that point I
was like it's finally I'm gonna sell
crypto for cash for the first time I
that was the first time you sold crypto
for cash oh pretty much you know I had
sold small amounts in the past but for
the that was the first time I cash out
some real money and I don't regret it
because I looked at XIV and I was like
all right right now it has a hundred and
eleven billion dollar market cap 333
billion undiluted I mean there was
something crazy and yet nobody in the
world was using it I mean I mean it was
no use
I had bet on X or P because I thought
hey this bank friendly cryptocurrency
could be a great idea but fundamentally
just like at a pure fundamental level no
banks were using it I mean that we're
watching capital we were an investor in
ripple I love ripple I mean they're
they're their software was actually
getting implemented in banks across the
world I mean they were one of the most
promising startups in in our portfolio I
mean I was encouraging watching Capital
guys so that's my secondary it's like I
wanted to buy secondaries I loved ripple
the company but XRP uh
just what it wasn't getting adopted in
in the way that it had been outlined or
or suggested that it would be and to
this day that remains true I don't own
any way coin we think I like coin
garbage trash just oh my god I mean talk
about just a [ __ ] corn like I love
Charlie Lee I remember like that the
very first MIT Bitcoin conference dinner
we were we were in the urinals taking a
piss
and I'm like Charlie like what value
does Bitcoin does like coin have
over bitcoin you didn't really have an
answer and I was like art this is
exactly what I thought it was what what
is one project that nobody knows about
or nobody's talking about that they
should be the I've got a startup that's
about to come out it's called a union
market or union marketplace the CEOs
prodigious he reminds me of Joey or
Vitalik as eight with even better social
skills I love those guys but I mean he's
very sociable based here we were his
first investor they're about to go live
be announced and very exciting stuff
pretty much creating a staking
marketplace and if staking becomes what
it is this is going to be an essential
part of that economy all right and
before we go through the lightning round
you have a new company that is not
crypto related I do but you're living in
Miami I am
tell us about crypto Castle Miami and
unless I with a new startup well crypto
he has on Miami I mean I've run the
social impact fund when thinking about
the socially impactful nature of crypto
assets mabashi technology I I mean I
always knew the United States was not an
interesting market but then I started to
travel around the world and I slowly but
surely developed a thesis that Latin
America was the rapists market in the
world
for crypto acid and bossy and technology
adoption and so but some people may say
well what about East Asia well you've
got WeChat and all II pay and in the
Chinese hegemony like no it's not
interesting there then you look at a
place like Africa you've already got
mobile money I mean they've already
leapfrog the banking system and that's
not volatile once again they've already
got like good payment systems I mean it
could use some improvement but Africa
not that interesting and and I saw I was
saying look it's a lot of America people
are like you have to go to the Middle
East North Africa and I was like okay so
I just went I just went I did a Gulf
State tour guess what
financial services arm adoption like
whether it's Bay
or mobile money anything in the Middle
East and Gulf states 16% how the hell
are you gonna get your Bitcoin if you
don't have a bank account or any way to
digitize your cash there I mean talk
about the unbanked I mean they have got
nothing there there there is no
infrastructure for people getting into
kryptek so I've got I am beyond certain
that Latin America is gonna see massive
adoption of this technology faster than
anywhere else we're seeing we're seeing
the beginnings of that and in Argentina
and Venezuela even in Brazil where I
just was and so I wanted to be close to
that I and I you know I found that that
Silicon Valley had reached the point of
diminishing returns for me so I wanted
to live someone close to Latin America I
wanted somewhere that was different from
San Francisco and a place that was warm
and fun and I landed on Miami and
decided to replicate what I had done
with the San Francisco crypto Castle but
really getting an actual castle this
time so you've got a mansion in Miami
with a pool looks pretty cool
you've got yachts jet skis the whole
nine yards and people can basically join
as a member of the crypto castle Network
income today whenever whenever depending
on their membership yeah it's a bit of a
business I'm just trying to break even
not pay rent but that's it I'm just
trying but more importantly you know
Miami is probably the best hub
especially in the winter for popular
culture and what's important about that
is not today but a couple years down the
line for my portfolio companies and for
the industry as a whole we're gonna have
to cross the chasm a mainstream adoption
and people are gonna need to be talking
about that so guess what I'm doing I'm
evangelizing rappers and DJs and artists
and Instagram models and all the and you
know government officials from Latin
America anyone that's interesting that's
coming to Miami they're probably coming
through the crypto Castle they're
hearing about it you know if they're
interested in crypto they're coming if
they're not interested in crypto and I
want them to be interested I can make it
happen and so it actually might might
impact
ability to move this industry forward is
perhaps greater in Miami then it is in
San Francisco simply because I'm the
only tech guy that I'm the only young
tech entrepreneur and all OH
all right so but explain why you're
starting a non tech company so why am i
starting a non tech company made men a
big made man I had the thing about
entrepreneurism an well so the thing
about entrepreneurship is that it's it's
about solving a real problem in your
life and my problem is is I like to go
out at night I like to have sleepless
nights I don't like to take care of my
body as much as I probably should and
you know my skin bears the brunt of that
poor decision-making and it just Dhruv
drove me nuts that you know I would have
a long night wake up next to the girl I
was dating I go in the shower I'd wash
my face I'd have a coffee she'd be in
the bathroom for three minutes we both
be getting ready to go over to work she
looked good as new and I would look like
a train wreck and people would notice
first thing when I walk into a meeting
or an office they'd say oh looks like
you had a long night and I hated that
that's like why don't men have these
options so then I would go on TV or do a
documentary about crypto and they'd put
makeup on my face and in three minutes
I looked better I was like wow this is
crazy you know like like this feels like
something that needs to be done and so I
knew for a couple of years that this was
interesting but then but then I realized
that it could be done you're you're
obviously not selling makeup to men but
you are selling you're selling a
skincare solution that improves how
their face look it looks immediately and
so I looked up what men are already
wearing they're using they're using SPF
obviously they're using moisturizer
they're using anti-aging
anti-inflammatories if they have
breakouts I was like why don't create a
five in one solution and keep it all
natural and then just have a tint you
know women have these tinted
moisturizers just have a tint that just
evens out their face makes them look
better and there's all their skincare
solutions that want
one of the coolest things we're doing
with this is that we're creating an like
a home applicator and a travel
applicator and we're taking these
jewel-like
cartridges that people can just replace
so it's gonna be a monthly shipment and
it's just gonna be cartridges that you
plug into the travel applicator the home
applicator that makes it super easy to
use all your skincare solutions in one
in the future we can add more kind of
products that have that cartridge and
just creating something that's really
dynamic you know it's not taking away
from what I'm doing in crypto I've got a
fabulous team but it was it was one of
those moments as an entrepreneurial it's
like this is a market this is an
opportunity this is something I can do
right now and so I'm doing it one of the
first guys to do AI CEO and a security
token sale is hopefully gonna be one of
the first guys to do men's skincare all
right before we wrap up rapid-fire
questions what's the most important
company in crypto without a doubt it's
coinbase because while they may not be
as big as a place like a company like
finance they are incredibly important to
the u.s. crypto ecosystem they are the
on-ramp for virtually anyone that wants
to buy crypto and until crypto assets
and blockchain technology moves beyond a
speculative technology where people want
to use crypto for another reason
coin basis that company and we can't
shake that we can't change that I don't
think anyone comes close I mean I think
by Nantz is great for on the global
stage the fact is is that coin base is
in San Francisco and it is the on-ramp
for the US economy to get involved in
this technology and that's not changing
anytime soon
so when they missed up it's bad but
frankly they've never had a hack you
know for all their misgivings they may
have about coinbase
I really truly believe that they are a
good company for this industry and with
if something truly existential were to
happen to them
it would be a really bad moment for that
way that would be bad yeah sure what one
regulation would you change or improve
if you could money transmission loss you
know I am a major donor to coin Center
for this very purpose the fact is that
if you're a fin tech startup and doing
anything that resembles the transition
transmission of money you have to get
registered and every every state in the
Union California
I mean coin B still does not have its
money transmission license in California
and like 15 other states I mean it's
insane and so what what coin Center is
working on and I think we'll have to do
this in a big it will have to be part of
a big bill won't be done on its own is a
federal money transmission charter it
becomes a states right issue but at the
end of the day I mean if you're fin tech
startup your life is a nightmare
and it maintains the oligopoly of
financial technology companies it's hard
to be innovative in this space unless
you have millions of dollars in years of
time to get the proper licensing and
every single state and that and that's
just not fair if we want to see
innovation in that sector most important
book you've ever read the art of war
soon's a-- why i read it twice a year
because one it instructed my college
majored so it was my inspiration for my
college major but once you realize that
you can approach life tactically in
every situation treat every moment like
warfare whether it's work or personal
relationships or romance it doesn't
matter when you can approach everything
tactically start to think several steps
ahead think defensively and offensively
with that kind of military mindset you
win more they're just more successful
that and that was so enlightening so I
guess even more essential was the fact
that Larry Ellison said that this is
this is the most important book that
he's right it was on the back of the
book you know Napoleon Bonaparte day
that
one tax that he kept and his saddlebag I
mean it is it just shows how thinking
tactically it transcends the battlefield
it is something that you've applied here
your life every single day and it's so
important to think about because you
avoid the missteps one would take when
they act with their emotions if you can
step back from your emotions and think
really with a forward-looking mentality
you'll always be more successful or
aliens real I think that aliens if if
they don't exist now they have existed
in the history of the universe but if
you look at how humanity has evolved you
know in 200 years we've gone from you
know [ __ ] in the streets and riding
horses landing on the moon and and
signing putting Rovers on Mars and on
the constant brink of nuclear apocalypse
you know I think it's very likely and
there's there's a good theorem for this
so they forget that there's a good
likelihood that any intelligent enough
civilization will necessarily destroy
itself and so I think you know if you
took a thousand advanced civilizations
alien or human regardless you know the
majority of them would destroy
themselves and so yes I think they're
aliens or there have been aliens but but
you I take a cautious approach to
extraterrestrials they're gonna come
hang out one day I hope so I mean or
I'll go hang out with them I'm down I
mean Elon and I can go take a shuttle
I'm ready all right well one question
you have for me what is the most
important new last lesson you learned
from serving in the military
you can't force people to follow you can
only earn their you can't force somebody
to follow you but you can earn the right
to lead them which is very nuanced but
even in the military where it's very
hierarchical and there's this sense of
like this is my rank and it's higher
than yours and so do what I say the best
leaders in the military do not try to
force followers they instead earn the
right to lead and there's a lot of very
little things that the military teaches
you about how to do that things as
simple as you know officers eat last
right noncommissioned officers eat
second-to-last and what you find is the
people who have spent the most time in
the classroom and in training they think
that you can force followers the people
who have spent the most time at war
understand that you have to earn
leadership and I think that that is a
lesson I'm incredibly grateful for and
also one that also applies to
non-military situations as well
virtually everything you learn in the
military you can apply to real life and
and this is actually I love that because
what I tell my entrepreneurs is like
look you can't make people listen to you
but you can make them respect you and
and and that like you said that
Newmont's is so important because
without that understanding they'll
they'll never follow you they'll never
listen to you and you'll never build a
great company but if you can be someone
that is respected then you can
accomplish anything
I completely agree all right man listen
I appreciate you coming there's been a
lot of fun I'm coming to Miami
I can't wait I that you're scaring me
but I'm coming
and we will have to do this again in a
couple of months to catch up on
everything yes there are always updates
we had in lots more to talk about